[Music]
elon musk's
company tesla yeah decided to buy
1.5 billion dollars worth of bitcoin
yeah and accept
bitcoin uh in terms of like purchasing
their automobiles
yes it's a huge move yeah
because in a lot of ways it stabilizes
crypto yes i mean when you think about
it
i don't know if there are any other
massive car companies that are openly
accepting
bitcoin as currency but not only
accepting it
investing it in terms of like the future
of grazie
yeah right huge move right is this
strategic
or is this the world's richest man
doing fun billionaire [ __ ] i think is
batman buying out the opera house
i think it's strategic i think somebody
was explaining to me how
they're still like who's this guy
michael berry the guy who called the
housing crisis
he's apparently still shorting tesla
he's like tesla's gonna crash
this i think and i didn't understand the
mechanics but one guy i know who really
who's been telling me to buy bitcoin
since 600 but
i didn't because i'm an idiot he was
like this stabilizes tesla stocks and
this is going to keep [ __ ] the short
people because they're not
this keeps them from falling and i don't
understand the mechanics of that
but i can see how that could be true i
just can't connect the dots
does that make sense that's interesting
because if even if tesla
doesn't live up to the expectations of
the stock price
yeah their holdings in bitcoin yeah will
inflate the company because their cash
reserves are going to grow
at the same velocity bitcoin yeah
oh yeah yeah go no on tesla
right now they're valued at every other
car american car company combined
like 834 billion dollars but
i think alon we know he's playing a
longer game where it's like it's about
the battery it's about the solar panels
about the home
system so it's like he's buying that
time to prove that the value of tesla's
not in the just the cars
which apparently they make the money
from like selling the credits
some like uh credits or something so i
think that he
he knows the short sellers are coming
after him he's doing this to buy time
where like the big stuff all the things
that are happening the gigafactory are
going to prove
what the value of tesla is it's a tech
company it's a gotcha
so this gives him enough time to
increase the value of the company
to where it matches the value of the
stock
and sometimes where there's a
discrepancy right there that's where you
can have somebody win on a short yeah
right obviously gamestop is a perfect
example it's like
the stock was overvalued we all know it
was overvalued that's why [ __ ]
are trying to short it
yeah this is interesting so he's trying
to do things that just pump up the
company
outside of making cars it's really
brilliant that's why he's a goat low key
that's what he is yeah like how many
people invest in tesla simply because
they're like nah that's the smartest guy
on the planet he'll figure it out yep
that's 100 why
why i believe in tesla so if he realizes
his own celebrity and decision making
is beneficial to the stock price of his
company
he's just adding he's diversifying his
company
without creating more product that's
[ __ ] brilliant that is brilliant
that is [ __ ] brilliant if if at the
end of the day this is all perception
and most of these [ __ ] numbskulls
that buy stock know absolutely
nothing about the company's dynamics or
how much money they're bringing or any
of that [ __ ] they're literally doing it
because it's cool
yeah well what's [ __ ] cool right now
crypto yep
i'm gonna dump money in crypto and i'm
gonna do it through tesla not my
personal money yeah he could have done
it with his personal
yeah guys the richest man on the planet
yeah could have bought 1.5 billion of
personal style he says no
tesla owns that stock that's a good
point i also
think i always [ __ ] playing chess
dude and i think he's smart it's not
just his perception i think
he's smart in this because i actually
think crypto is a good long-term play
i don't know if bitcoin is going to be
the winner right you and i were starting
to text about this like
i have not put nearly enough into crypto
but to me it just makes perfect sense
that there will be some global currency
yeah you said this is interesting
if the world is flat which it is
countries are all very connected
why do we still have something by flat
they say the world is flat it was a book
that was written like 15 years ago which
is basically saying
now with the internet i can connect with
somebody in another country
in an instant it's not like before when
i was a kid
a phone call to india sounded like
garbage you're yelling in the [ __ ]
phone so i could hear you
you're legit writing letters that are
taking a week to get there yeah now
email i can talk to somebody in india
just as fast as i can
email you your cousin on whatsapp
texting my cousin and whatsapp it is the
exact same
thing yeah yeah we're all connected now
yep travel between countries is gonna
get easier and easier
connectivity is borderless
yes so that is the often probably the
first thing
that reduces borders right yeah yeah
interconnectivity interdependence
on communication not even commerce yeah
how can i communicate with these people
yeah
right once you start that communication
like
culture starts to blend
like european culture you go to all
these different countries yeah they got
their different languages but i think
we've spoken about this podcast it's the
same [ __ ] thing
yeah they act like they're all like woke
because they're so accepting of one
another it's like you all believe the
same [ __ ] thing you look the same you
look the same you act the same you dress
the [ __ ] same you're not woke you're
not me accepting somebody from nebraska
that's more different you know you're
right you're right we are
more yeah different yeah in this country
between state and state than they are
100 yeah that is interesting yeah that's
an interesting play i wonder
in belgium there's new york in new
jersey what are we talking about it's
the same [ __ ]
absolutely but as we get more connected
and it's gonna we're all gonna be
working from home i think relatively
soon
you're gonna be doing virtual reality
meetings yeah
there's no difference between me and a
guy in indonesia and a guy in the bra
it all feels the same yeah so to meet oh
you just dropped your [ __ ] laptop
okay got it so to me it just makes sense
that at some point as
everything becomes connected we have one
currency that connects us and you don't
have to exchange
so i don't know if bitcoin is going to
be the one that comes out on top yeah
but some global currency has to arise
yes now here's the question the american
government
is willing to do whatever it takes
to protect the dominance yes of the
american dollar yes
historically speaking we've got a
restaurant for this we have gone to
warfare yeah yeah
we've spoken about the petrol dollar on
this podcast our
dollar is backed by the purchase
of oil yeah okay all the oil that is
sold by saudi arabia
is purchased in american dollars and any
country that has tried
to sell their oil in a currency there's
not american dollars all of a sudden
there's a little insurrection all of a
sudden there's a little war
yeah going on right yeah libya iraq
right i think libya wants to create like
an african currency i think iraq wants
to sell
oil directly to france and all of a
sudden it's like oh
you know what is it now wasn't it was
saying whatever
tricky ass name so that was saying
it's a bad man we got to go take him out
again so
we're willing to do whatever it takes
yeah millions of lives
lost yeah over the protection of the
american dollar
as the world's currency because it is
the world's currency yeah
right i cannot fathom
that the united states government as
diabolical as it is in its
decision-making
yeah okay zero regard for human life
yeah i cannot fathom that they would be
completely okay
with bitcoin becoming
the world's currency if they did not
have a stronghold
over bitcoin yeah whatever like we talk
about playing chess whatever chess we
think we're playing
the u.s government is playing on a
different level and the chinese
government probably that's their
competition
they're probably playing on a very high
level but yes i the governments will i
think essentially decide which crypto
comes out on top
yes but i do think that's again it's
just
logical to have a global currency so
that's 100 logical and we do have one
it's called the us dollar
and they would be giving up the us
dollar
now i this is what again maybe the
united states government or intelligence
knows something about bitcoin right that
the average person does not
you know maybe there are people who
started bitcoin i mean
if i started a currency you better
believe i might hide a little for myself
we don't know we're going to start a
currency we'll start currency one but
i'm just saying hypothetically speaking
if we started a currency right
i would make some bitcoins for myself
and just hold them just in case some
[ __ ] popped off i'd like to have some
bitcoins if they were
you know incredibly lucrative would you
not 100 apparently there are these
stashes of bitcoin
that people know and say exist but they
don't know
how much they're worth right so i think
uh
in bitcoin their version of like the
penny but it's like one one millionth
of a bitcoin is called a satoshi is that
familiar have you guys heard of this
isn't that that's named after the
creator i guess
maybe but apparently japanese dude yeah
apparently
he has some stash worth billions of
dollars somewhere but nobody can account
for it
so who knows if all of a sudden in the
future
we find out that there's way more
bitcoin out there than we thought and
it's way less controlled than we thought
and then everybody goes oh [ __ ] i
thought this was a control substance you
have to mine for her and it costs all
this money to mine for and blah blah
blah and you realize that your thing is
worth absolutely nothing maybe that
could happen
i just cannot fathom the united states
government with all of its power and
control and influence around the world
would just
allow a global currency to pop up
without having a stake in it
it's going to be mind-boggling it's
going to be tough to control is the only
thing i can think of
i mean they'll probably find their way
but bitcoin seems like that's part of
the beauty
of it is it is uncontrollable and to be
if you're like um
you want to get rid of the fed one of
the big things you don't like that the
fed did is they made it a fiat currency
if we go to bitcoin as far as we know
this could be [ __ ] like you said as
far as we know there's only x amount so
that is your new gold standard
there's only x amount of gold on earth
there's only x amount of bitcoin on
earth
this is the new now we're back that's
what we assume yeah that's what yeah
that's what i'm saying it could be full
of [ __ ] could be wrong
right and there's validity to that but
that is the beauty of bitcoin if you're
like a
[ __ ] the fed guy what they can't control
bitcoin as far as we know i guess i'm
just saying like when it comes to big
tech we're like oh yeah united states
government is in bed with facebook and
that's why they let
you know facebook kind of do whatever
they want because they exchange
information with facebook and
everything's good
yeah right we have all this information
and data on people in other countries
and how they
interact and how they might want to vote
and how they live their lives and then
we can influence them through this tool
i think that was the big issue with tick
tock right it was like whoa whoa whoa
whoa
we're the ones that make the social
media apps yeah and then we get all the
data from all the other countries we
can't have the chinese motherboard
100 yeah home team let's go it's [ __ ]
up but it is what it is
it better what you better you than me
the enemy i know is better than the one
i don't know fair enough yeah
so basically i just cannot find it i
mean like
hasn't the u.s like destroyed any sort
of uh
you know tax havens or any sort of like
illegal money
allocations like around the world like
you have the cayman islands destroyed
switzerland
the swiss bank destroyed the panama
papers i think panama you can it's like
hard to launder money right now
and bitcoin is this tool that's used to
launder money all the [ __ ] time
yeah zero crack down on it
it just seems odd doesn't it it's tough
because it's not tied to a government
you can't if you want to wage war on
libya you can do that yeah you could put
some pressure on panama you could put
some pressure on it i can't overthrow
your government
but you can't put some pressure on who
do i overthrow at bitcoin
[Applause]